nico rosberg welcome to you tell us
what is extreme e and what are you
trying to achieve with it
xtreme is a new motorsports championship
it's based on fully electric off-road
buggies
and we're really here to raise awareness
for climate change um but also
have local impact with projects that
we're supporting so it's really the
first sport
sport that's built on a social purpose
and talk us through the locations that
you've chosen for the various races
and why they've been picked out
so we've carefully picked these
spectacular locations around the world
like for example racing uh near the
glacier in greenland
but unfortunately at the same time these
locations are the ones that have
been damaged most by climate change and
we're racing there because
first of all we want to support the
local initiatives and the locals
in their fight against climate change
but also secondly we want to raise
awareness for climate change and really
show people around the world what's
happening around around the planet
and has your experience with extreme e
may you reflect at all on your time
in formula one any environmental regrets
formula one let's not forget has already
done a lot also for mobility i mean
we've been pioneering lightweight
materials we've pioneered the
turbocharged engines
pioneered hybrid engines which is a
great contemporary
powertrain solution at the moment very
efficient um but at the same time i'm
also proud because
f1 is doing more and more um to also
become more sustainable uh pledging to
be carbon neutral by 2030
and this is where extreme e is really
trail blazing we're already a carbon
neutral event now
powered by hydrogen energy um and we're
doing a lot you know really launching
these initiatives around the world to
have real impact
tangible impact locally and that's what
i love about xtreme
okay nico stay with me because in a
moment we're also going to be speaking
to adam
bond from afc energy who supply the
power for
the extreme e-cars but first we can show
you now what the racing looks like
these pictures here are from the first
race which took place
in saudi arabia johan christopher's in
doing the switch and
on that switch they picked up a
one-minute penalty and it really ends in
what could have been
a really nice lead for them they would
have been top qualifier they were about
four
so adam bond welcome to you you're
involved in the technology behind the
fueling of these cars hydrogen fuel
cells so explain to us how they work and
just how green are they sure look
hydrogen fuel cells is a zero emission
power generator really
our systems that we've designed for the
extreme e uh championship
from from from racing in alula all the
way through to greenland amazon
at every one of the locations that
nico's reference you know the idea is to
generate
zero emission power to charge the cars
to promote and be
fully consistent with the sustainable
message of the of the extreme e
championship so uh we are generating
zero emission power
it's displacing diesel generation and uh
it's really big
it's a first uh first of its kind for
for international motor racing and
we believe international sporting and we
saw some pictures nico of that first
race in saudi arabia so talk us through
it how did it go
i'm so proud so we as team rxr rosberg x
racing we dominated the whole weekend
and came away with a win the first ever
extreme race win
um and that makes me very very proud so
um and as you know equality is also a
big
part in the sport so we want to we
wanted to create a platform
which really allows women equal
opportunity
to the men um and so every team has a
female and male driver
and both my uh both molly taylor and
johann christopherson who are our two
drivers did a fantastic job out there
and uh yeah it's really exciting to get
going and be leading the championship in
this way
and now i'm looking forward to senegal
which is the second race at the end of
may
and adam a big part of formula one's
emissions actually comes from
international travel doesn't it so give
us an idea of how you're trying to
minimize
air freight how are you doing that
okay extremely have taken a lot of uh
the initiative here and and
using uh the saint helena uh as a former
uh sort of a
royal mail shipping uh or boat to to
move all of the cars
all of the equipment you yeah our fuel
cell around uh
from from race to race so the idea is
that uh as it says on the side of the of
the ship you know not electric yet
uh this is all about creating that sort
of move towards a more sustainable
championship and that includes
movement of our freight from location to
location so uh yeah we're very very
very pleased to be on board that ship i
think as we speak and nico
what can formula one learn from what
you're doing here
let's let's open this up bigger what can
the sports world learn of what we're
doing here
because this sport can be such a
powerful vehicle for positive change
and we want to inspire the sports world
in this direction and everybody
and everybody who's following all the
fans around the world let me give you a
few examples i mean
look at arsenal they have a battery
system in their stadium
which is entirely filled with renewable
energy sources
and which powers them their entire
90-minute matches
so their their matches are completely
co2 neutral so this is a
soccer team that's really leading the
way as well the olympics are going
climate positive by 2030.
so there's various examples but it's
really about embracing
all the fans and creating a movement
with the whole sports community
to really do our part you know everybody
needs to do their part against climate
change
and um and this is what we're about we
want to trailblaze
and adam what about not just sport but
the wider decarbonization of industry
what part do you think that hydrogen can
play in that
well i i fully endorse what nick i said
this is not just about motor motorsport
racing this is about decarbonizing
an industry which is very much heavily
reliant on diesel whether that's
temporary power for construction sites
temporary power for
for sporting races all the way through
to decarbonization of maritime it
it starts to create that impetus uh
motorsport and sport in general is a
tremendous platform to bring people
together
and actually create messaging around
that and and for us
this is about decarbonizing a race but
hopefully creates a platform for a far
greater decarbonization we've got a long
way to go
before we get to net zero aspirations of
governments in society and this is all
about creating
those steps along that journey and nico
i can really feel the enthusiasm that
you have
for this project how does the job
satisfaction
compare to winning formula one races and
titles
well thank you for asking that's so
beautiful for me that i wasn't sure if i
would ever ever be able to relive
the emotions that i had in formula one
when winning and yet now here winning
the first race
i really those emotions came back to me
um and it was so beautiful so i'm very
very fortunate to be able to
relive some of these emotions now
through extreme
well nico rosberg and adam bond we
appreciate your time thanks so much for
joining us today
thank you